Colorado Springs.
Families affected by the deadly shooting
at an LGBTQ club
gathered for Thanksgiving dinner
where they could mourn
the five people lost together.
There has also been a remarkable
show of support for one of the heroes
in that attack.
Richard Fiero took down the shooter
and with the help of two others,
beat the gunman.
Stopping the rampage
hero and his wife own a local brewery.
And in a Thanksgiving Day message,
they thanked supporters
who showed up to their business
and said they've been flooded
with company T-shirt orders
He are overwhelmed
by the love and support
everyone is giving us.
And we feel it.
All the comments,
just an outpouring of love
and it's beautiful
and we just want to thank everyone.
We are very, very, very,
very grateful for every one of you.
As part of your party,
that will be the family home.
Our intent is to keep
to field everybody's
request and get everybody assured.
It may take us a year.
It may take us ten days. Who knows?
And Richard joins me now.
Richard, I'll take one of those T-shirts
to my hats off to you
for for your heroism.
Tonight marks one week
since this horrific attack happened.
Tell us how you're doing
We just got done
with a celebration of life.
And, you know,
this isn't this is a life changing event
where everybody
in their building and
and their families and their friends.
Yesterday, we were able to
open our brewery
and the girls that worked
there wanted to do so
for more or more for community to gather.
And it was a beautiful, beautiful day.
I couldn't think enough people.
I tried to thank everyone
that walked through the door.
But it was it was something that that I'm
very thankful
that that everybody's showing love.
And hopefully we can we can
we can do a lot more of that.
And the president called you.
Tell us about that call.
What what did he have to say?
And I guess what has that been like?
Well, I listen, I'm just I'm
just a young kid. I grew up in San Diego.
I never expected to ever talk
to a president,
more or less
be around with any of that stuff,
a governor, a mayor.
I am humbled,
you know, at the end of the day.
I wish everybody could talk to him
just just to have that honor
I'm a I'm an old soldier.
For me
just to talk to the commander in chief
is is a big deal.
So, you know,
the discussion was between us
and I and I was very grateful
that he took the time to say
thank you
and and just kind of
send his condolences about the families.
And Richard, you had a week to reflect
on what's happened.
And I know you must be going through
so many different emotions.
I'm just curious,
what changes would you like to see?
We know the president has been saying
in the last couple of days
that he would like to see the country
take another
try at an assault weapons
ban in this country.
I mean, obviously,
that's going to be difficult to get past.
But do you have any thoughts on
what you would like to see,
what needs to happen in this country
so we don't have any more of these
mass shootings?
Well, Jim, I'll be honest.
I was trained on a weapon
as a as a soldier.
I respect weapons.
My wife's got a concealed carry license.
License.
I mean, we
we we own guns
and we don't own guns, but we we
we work with guns.
So, again, it's something for the nation
to figure out in the end
and whether that's administration
doesn't matter to me.
I would just like people
to stop having so much anger.
You know, it
shouldn't be something that's tense.
There's no reason for somebody
to to go to a dance club
or a show or anything
and have to worry about being shot.
I don't know
if that has anything to do with guns.
I just think people need to be
a little bit nicer to each other.
Absolutely.
And your family's brewery just reopened
for the first time
since the mass
shooting
and people were lined up outside.
Tell us about this reception
and this outpouring of love
that your business has received
since the shooting.
Yeah, it was it was it was humbling.
I I literally
we did not plan on being there.
We didn't want to make this a thing.
And, you know, it was just so much
we had to go back and help the girls
with with everything
they Everybody wiped us out.
It was it was beautiful.
As a business person.
And it was more beautiful
as a person
to see
the variance,
that difference,
the adversity,
exclusion of everyone there.
Everybody in the same room
just having some joy and enjoying a beer.
You know,
I tried to shake everyone's hand
and think of all I'm not a hero.
You know, everybody else in that room
was a hero with us.
Everybody's got a hero story
to just try and survive.
And we lost five.
And there's still many more in the house.
One more.
My wife just went down to go
see our friends, Chip and Joanne.
And, you know,
they got a long road to go.
And when all these cameras are gone,
we're still going to
be live in this thing.
And I mean, that that is the issue is,
isn't it,
Richard is
in that
we're probably going
to have another one of these.
We have had one
since what happened in Colorado Springs.
We had the mass shooting
at the Wal-Mart and Virginia.
I guess
what are your thoughts on that,
that this keeps happening
in this country over and over again?
Again, like I said,
I think just people need to start
loving each other, man.
I hug and shake hands with folks
yesterday
that I'd never seen or met in my life.
I think folks need to do a little bit
more of that.
And, you know,
there's this whole anger thing.
And in people
picking teams, it's not cool.
We all need to shake hands
and move forward, move to the action.
And that action needs to be more caring
and more love across across this nation.